welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of X-Men
the Last Stand this 2006 film was Fox's
third X-Men movie and we are breaking
down all of these films in our X-Men
stick stick rewatch directed by Brett
Ratner this film is remembered for some
questionable choices and some trouble
behind the scenes but it led to Kelsey
Grammar Beast returning for the
post-credit scene of the Marvels a cameo
that proves that all of the fox X-Men
films are on the table for MCU
Crossovers and we must watch them all
even the less loved ones were people
start saying [__] a lot keep it up I'll
spray you in the face [__] I'm the
Juggernaut [__] I know but there's also
a lot to Love in This film so let's
break down Xmen the last stand for all
the Easter eggs details you missed and
what else besides Frasier Marvel Studios
might bring back for the mutant
Homecoming in Deadpool 3 and by the way
any speculation or potential spoilers
for that Deadpool 3 film will be down in
the danger room section at the end of
this video okay as always the opening
20th Century Fox logo has the X
lingering just a bit longer on that fade
to black but then the Marvel logo of all
the flipping comic book pages has
actually been updated to include moments
that are related to what happens in this
film we see genan gray as Phoenix saying
I am Phoenix from Uncanny X-Men number
101 in 1976 that was the first
appearance of Phoenix years before Chris
claremont's dark Phoenix Saga would
begin in 1980 and in the opinions of
many Revitalize Marvel Comics as a brand
like there's a reason why in The
Stranger Things pilot will in the year
1982 is reading an issue from the dark
Phoenix Saga Xmen 134 because that story
line was so important to really any kid
reading Marvel Comics in the early ' 80s
and that included this movie
screenwriters Simon kinberg and Zack pin
kinberg loved the story line so much
that he tried to adapt it again with
2019s dark Phoenix but it's really a
tough storyline nowadays because you can
say that Marvel has really refocused its
overpowered aega level Nexus mutant
female roll into the Scarlet Witch and
it's kind of hard to also do that story
and be like aren't these women crazy but
hey it could still be fun to see these
two fight in secret Wars I think we need
to see it happen not in like a RAR way
but like they're they're very powerful
very cool characters and I just want to
see them at least like talk or maybe
like Team Up and Kill a bunch of guys
whatever I I feel bad for telling you
what to do okay we also see this comic
issue of Jubilation Lee saying Adam anti
man attitude he's one of a kind we'd
like him back this is actually from
Chris Claremont and Jim Lee's X-Men
number seven from 1992 a shot of Magneto
with the Box above him saying the
government SE challenge didn't see it
that way this is from Claremont and
Lee's X-Men number one in 1991 we see
several other images from this early 90s
run which is pretty great that's when
Wolverine's colors were like this auburn
red and yellow we also see this image of
Magneto ripping up the bridges of New
York obviously foreshadowing Magneto
destroying the Golden Gate Bridge in
this movie we see a few pages from the
very first Uncanny X-Men number one all
the way back from 1963 by Stanley and
Jack Kirby which introduced the X-Men
the lineup included Professor X Cyclops
Iceman who kind of looks like a cloud
angel and the Beast and this is before
the Beast was blue but he was barefoot
in this movie beast and Angel are
introduced to X-Men films we see an
image of Colossus fighting Juggernaut
that's from Uncanny X-Men number 102 in
1976 we also see Juggernaut from X-Men
number 46 that's this cover and then we
see this image of Wolverine telling
Cyclops every now and then Summers and
that line actually completes with I
remember why you're still in charge this
is from Jos Sweden's astonishing X-Men
number eight from 2005 which would have
made this one of the more recently
published inclusions for this 2006 movie
whatever you think about Jos Sweden his
X-Men run in the first half of that
decade was really good and I like that
they include this moment when Cyclops
pulled a get off my lawn and cleared a
whole field with his optic blast this
movie unfortunately kills off the
Cyclops character in a pretty shitty way
but weeden's astonishing X-Men was known
for the mutant cure storyline that fox
wanted to bring into this film to make
it a political conflict with Magneto but
doing so made kimberg and pin's dark
Phoenix elements kind of in congruous so
this film opens 20 years ago which would
make it either 1986 or based on the
October 2005 issue of the magazine Hank
McCoy's reading later maybe 1985 but but
either way this movie dages Patrick
Stewart and Ian McKellen in a very
high-profile stunt technology had been
used that way more discreetly in movies
like Terminator 3 but these visual
effects from Lola very talented group of
artists just kind of come out front and
center in the opening frames of this
movie and initially the effect is pretty
good it holds up it's because this shot
begins on really the surprise of Charles
Xavier's feet hitting the ground because
back in this time he was still able to
walk the shot keeps the men at a
distance we can't really see their
mouths as closely from this angle and
the shot is in motion so we're just not
really scrutinizing the movement of
their lips which is the way we get
sucked in the uncanny valley right away
like look at this clip I still don't
know why I'm here couldn't you just make
them say yes yes I could but it's not my
way yeah it's pretty good right because
here's the thing about VFX that social
media generally misses the point of
whenever these things are taken out of
context or paused or like zoomed in on
everything looks artificial you don't
look like a genius or posting something
on Twitter and being like doesn't this
look terrible yeah because you're
posting it on Twitter dumbass you look
terrible on Twitter the trick of
avoiding falling into the uncanny valley
is context and character and in this
case the context and the characters are
it's just nice to see these two old foes
back together as friends in a two shot
the daging effect supports that illusion
daging and facial deep fakes should
always be done in tandem with the
actor's physical performance and deliver
a magic trick that our hearts long to
see if it ever gets just the slightest
whiff of being exploitative our
Collective moral conscience is going to
shove us violently into that uncanny
valley and force us to hate it no matter
how good it looks and notice how it's
not until we are inside with a
stationary camera on a closeup with
McKellen and Stewart that we begin to
see the artificiality like here we're
mutants Jean we are like you but overall
it works I think because we are seeing
these two guys now from the point of
view of young Jean Gray who doesn't
trust these strangers they look creepy
and weird to her because we just heard
Charles's voice inside this girl's Mind
telepathically by the way seeing Charles
walking in this opening scene is part of
a different backstory that we don't
really get to see for these characters
X-Men first Class will establish a new
way that Charles Xavier gets paralyzed
from the waist down we also see a
different walking Charles Xavier in the
final scene of X-Men origins of
Wolverine so yeah just don't think about
it but I do like the detail that Eric is
wearing a red over coat that looks
similar to the red coat that Jean gry
will wear when she succumbs to the
Phoenix now already in the first like 30
seconds of the movie there are a lot of
insane visual effects going on and these
along with a Golden Gate Bridge sequence
made X-Men the Last Stand the most
expensive movie of all time at the time
of its release but that said
surprisingly this X-Men movie made more
money than either of its two
predecessors it was the most profitable
X-Men movie up until X-Men Days of
Future Past yeah it made more than Xmen
Orin Wolverine it made more than first
class now Jean Gray's Father John is
played by Adrienne hoe who voiced night
crawler for the '90s animated series The
Brochure is great but what about Jean
what about her illness if you are indeed
my brother then I will pray to God that
you find the wisdom to work work through
your hatreds while Charles has powers of
telepathy Eric lyer can telekinetically
move metal Jean Gray proves to have both
of these Powers lifting the cars outside
the neighbor whose lawnmower floats is a
cameo by Chris Claremont and stanlee
cameos as the neighbor with the hose
Charles asks Jean if she can control his
power or let it control her this movie
Alters the origin story of the Phoenix
as a separate entity establishing it as
kind of a separate mental entity or a
Persona or an alar that Jee creates as a
response to Charles's mental blocks but
of course in the comics the Phoenix
force is a cosmic entity that seeks out
and inhabits Jean's body from a young
age the origin of the Phoenix force is
one of the details of the 2019 dark
Phoenix film will change but the way
it's defined in this movie I just think
is kind of a bummer because now Jean's
power is associated with you know like
schizophrenia and back in the odds and
prior to that movies love to just throw
schizophrenia in there without really
understanding anything about the
condition this isn't a knock against
famy Jansen who does a great job in this
movie it's more of just like the script
decision to do this and they didn't need
to do this because X2 literally open
happens with a
fenixytb
train track in that drawer ych and the
shame of this father's voice on oh
God how do you this just reminds us that
these X-Men movies were a metaphor for
the LGBT experience and the pressure for
youth to hide themselves from the world
Brian singer's relationship with
franchise is obviously pretty
complicated given his sexual assault
allegations and his Frau relationship
with the cast and crew but after X2
singer and his writers left the
franchise to go make Superman Returns
Fox Studios originally hired Matthew vau
to replace Brian Singer but vau also
left the production at first it was
reported that he left to avoid uprooting
his family from the UK to Vancouver but
then just a few months ago October 2023
at New York Comic Con V said that he
actually quit X3 after seeing that a fox
executive had an alternate script draft
that opened with a prologue of of
African kids dying of thirst and a rora
Monro creating a thunderstorm to save
them which he thought was a really cool
idea but he said the executive actually
just planned to use this fake script to
get Hal Barry to sign on and then they
would have thrown this fake draft in the
bin and V said that he walked after that
which sounds like a pretty noble thing
until you realize what this guy did to
Darwin In First
[Music]
Class yes Matthew Bon would later return
to reboot the franchise and X-Men first
Class in 2011 before X3 after a scramble
to find a replacement director Fox hired
Brett Ratner best known for directing
the rush hour films later on in Fall
2017 Ratner would face sexual assault
allegations and Elliot Paige said that
Ratner outed the then 18-year-old Paige
as gay at an X3 meet and greet event
this was before Paige came out as a
trans man and a pacin was also at this
event and said that she witnessed it so
look folks we are allowed to rewatch
these movies like what we like in this
franchise but we just can't Sweep All
That history under the rug and pretend
it didn't happen so the past two X-Men
installments had opening titles that
showed nerve cells and brain sinking
with cerebro this one shows the blood
cells and antibodies of a mutant named
Jimmy AKA leech whose blood is harvested
by worthington's Pharma company to
produce a mutant cure this is actually
part of an original opening scene in
Worthington Labs where Dr raal would
have put Jimmy through an MRI type
machine but with the gene gray opening
instead we're already kind of feeling
the tug of war in this movie between the
dark Phoenix storyline in the Cure story
line but we see these DNA strands
through the lenses of a microscope which
is then locked behind the XO but instead
of cerebro we're now in a different part
of the expansion basement the danger
room the longtime X-Men training room
which operates with a kind of
holographic augmented reality in a
simulation against the Sentinels with
their giant robot heads similar to the
design of the '90s Animated Series but
redesign for days of future past but
this not too distant future in the
danger room is an apocalyptic war zone
that looks a lot like what the X-Men
will face in Days of Future pasts
prologue to Jackman Wolverine and Halle
Berry storm return leading this Mission
with Elliot page Kitty Pride Sean
Ashmore Bobby Drake and a pacin rogue
and Daniel Cudmore Colossus Colossus and
Rogue team up as Rogue absorbs his metal
up powers to deflect the debris
meanwhile Kitty hugs Bobby to let debris
pass through them which makes Rogue
jealous Wolverine lights a cigar on a
nearby flame reminding me of Mary and
Ravenwood stopping to sip some loose
booze and Raiders of the Lost AR Logan
says that this was his last cigar and
since we don't see real cigar in the
simulation floor later I assume this is
like a virtual cigar and Logan is
treating this exercise kind of like a
video game where he collects inventory
like cigars storm even calls us out this
isn't a game Logan like whoever designed
the danger room program must have
allowed Logan to smoke cigars inside
that simulation and I love that I assume
Scott Summers did this and he just did
this because deep down he really loves
Logan Logan tells Colossus to toss him a
move that he will do in the final battle
later this is the fastball special a
classic move that Wolverine and Colossus
have pulled off many times in the comics
first appearing in X-Men 100 by Chris
Claremont James Marston returns to Scott
Summers he's letting some of his Scruff
grow out as he is still mourning Jean
since James Marsen would have to leave
production early to go film Superman
Returns producer of this film decided to
kill off the character in the opening
act instead of you know any other
storyline that he could have shot in the
first few weeks of production films
don't have to be shot chronologically or
you could have like recast a character
why did you kill off the character
there's just a lot of confusing choices
in this movie like the dialogue in X3
just kind of dumbs down the characters
in ways that they weren't dumb in the
other films like this scene with Rogue
and Bobby have I ever put any pressure
on you you're a guy Bobby your mind's on
the on one thing and that's where the
scene ends like Bobby never contests
that it's kind of like yep got me there
it's 2006 guys are supposed to only have
one of the five love languages like in
X2 Bobby and Rogue figured out a system
you know quick denty nice kiss his
gloved peton so why is this an issue now
and by the end of this movie Rogue
dewers herself just so she can hold his
hand what okay on to the Department of
mutant Affairs presumably the political
result of Charles meeting with President
McKenna and X2 the quest of the federal
agency includes a DNA double helix
design on the shield Kelsey Grammar
plays secretary Hank McCoy hanging
upside down and reading this October
2005 edition of Scientific American
which is an actual publication that's
been in print since 1845 there's some
fun article titles in the cover like
Galactic waves the cosmic necessity of
beautiful spirals odd DNA reveals
secrets of human evolution migration and
survival tracking mutations the
Forgotten era of the brain control chips
building a better bomb detector ancient
crystals from Earth's first continents
now you might think these might be like
references to Galactus or the Phoenix
Force but no no no this is an actual
Scientific American cover from October
2005 now Kelsey Grammar is covered in
thick makeup and Prosthetics for this
movie when he returns to play the
character in the MCU in the Marvel's
post credit scene they do a CGI
rendering of the character that looks
like it's based on the bone structure of
what they use for Hulk and Thanos that
isn't making the character more comic
accurate like a smaller head in
proportion to the rest of his body but I
do appreciate the Practical effect here
Hank McCoy meets with the new US
president of this film played by ysf
summer Bill Duke plays dhf secretary
tras a natu bolevard tras creator of the
Sentinel program but tras in this movie
is never given a first name and we meet
a different bolevard tras played by by
Peter Dinklage and Days of Future Past
we learned that Mystique had been
impersonating TR so I guess she's moved
on from Senator Kelly and now she's
being interrogated by an FBI agent
played by Anthony heeld who played Dr
Chilton in the Silence of the Lambs and
returned in 2003's prequel red dragon
which Brett Ratner directed Mystique
says she doesn't answer to her slave
name of Raven darkholm and she
transforms into Magneto wearing his 001
prisoner clothes from X2 and then into
heal's character and I know I point this
out in every movie I love what other
actors like do a Mystique impression and
here Anthony heeld in the split screen
shot himself does the first part of the
stunt where he swipes the chair behind
his back at least before they cut to a
different angle and a stunt person is
swapped in when she holds him from
behind Mystique snars as a kind of
pejorative hom sapan so the president
passes McCoy a file on Jimmy AKA leech
leech in the comics was a member of the
morlocks with the power to drain or
suppress superpowered beings within 50
ft of him on his paperwork you can see
xdna strand KLH conjugate KLH or keynote
Limpet hemocyanin is used as a carrier
protein in the production of antibodies
Charles lectures about mutant ethics
Kitty pride is sitting in this classroom
and to the left is Shauna Kane returning
as Teresa Cassidy siren Connor widows
returns as Jones that's a kid who
blinked to change channels in X2 there's
Kia Wong back as Jubilation Lee she
doesn't get any lines in this movie
though Luke Paul returns is flea that is
the kid that Colossus gave that doodle
of Bobby and Rogue back in X2 Kitty
Pride quotes Albert Einstein the full
quote is actually I do not believe an
immortality of the individual and I
consider ethics to be an exclusively
human concern with no superhuman
Authority behind it it was in response
to a letter from a Baptist pastor in
1953 about whether or not Einstein felt
he had achieved everlasting life with
his creator but it's interesting here
that the term superhuman is used in a
different context Einstein was using the
word to talk about God taken out of
context historically now it's saying
that superhumans might be Gods Not Bound
by the same ethical principles as the
rest of humanity Charles puts it back in
the context that Einstein wasn't a
mutant at least they don't think which
begs the question that lots of
characters throughout history might have
actually been mutants and we just didn't
know Charles plays a recording from his
colleague Dr Moira MCT tager a
geneticist and mutant Ally from the
comics played by Olivia Williams in this
movie recast is Rose Burn in an expanded
role in X-Men first Class the comos
patient that Charles poses the
hypothetical of transferring a
Consciousness into sets up the twist in
the post credit scene storm and Charles
walked through the school passing this
kid floating paper airplanes this is
supposedly Julian Keller Helen and
behind them are some blonde triplets
these are the Stepford cucko clones of
Emma Frost from the comics secretary
McCoy joins them and briefs him about
the announced mutant cure he and
Wolverine trade barbs as two furry
fellas he tells Logan I've been fighting
for mutant right since before you had
claw boy not realizing that Logan AKA
James howlet is a lot older than Hank
McCoy Wolverine was born like in the
1840s we'll see that in Xmen Origins we
cut to Worthington Labs on Alcatraz in
San Francisco Bay X3 takes us to the
West Coast for an island known as a
prison historically in low Kei season 2
they'll actually visit Alcatraz and show
how three of the escapees were actually
variants at the TVA clocked now the
original idea for Alcatraz in this movie
was for a lot of mutants to be
imprisoned here they were going to use
the prison cells of Alcatraz to keep
mutants there and the reason Reon
Magneto was going to move the Golden
Gate Bridge to this island originally
was to liberate all these mutants and
let them flee into the city that set
piece of the Golden Gate Bridge was
insanely complicated it actually took up
a sixth of the film's budget the effects
crew had to Begin work on it while the
script was still coming together so then
when the script was changed so that
Alcatraz was just going to be used as
like a location where Worthington labs
are and the only mutant in prison there
is leech it just kind of makes it so
that in the final version of the film
Magneto moves the bridge like just to
move the Brotherhood from Marin County
to the island he could have just as
easily summoned a fleet of to carry them
across it would have taken far less
energy for Magneto and he would have
been far more useful in that battle on
the island so yeah the bridge scene
looks awesome but it's just kind of a
visual spectacle with no logical purpose
thank you to better help for sponsoring
this video A new year is a great excuse
for finally tackling the stuff that you
put off last year and if one of the
things you've been putting off until
2024 is taking proper care of your
mental health better help can help you
get started and hey no judgment for
waiting starting therapy can be hard and
the right therapist for you might not be
in your area and some people struggle
with the face- Toof face interaction of
therapy with better help you can have
your therapy sessions as a phone call as
a video chat or even via messaging if
you prefer that whatever is the most
comfortable version of therapy for you
just click the link in the description
and answer a few questions about what
you're looking for from therapy and what
your preferences are better help will
then match you with the therapist from
their Network that's right for you if
you don't really fit with that therapist
which is a common thing with therapy you
can easily switch to a therapist for no
additional cost without stressing about
insurance who is in your network or
anything like that if you think you
might benefit from therapy consider
betterhelp click the link in the
description or visit betterhelp.com
rockstars click that link helps support
this Channel and also gets you 10% off
your first month of better help so you
can connect with a therapist to see if
it helps you now working under Dr
Worthington is Dr Kavita raal played in
this movie by the prolific and wonderful
character actor shereé aashu Dr Ra comes
from the Cure storyline in the Jos weed
and run she is the scientist Who
develops the drug that they call poke
meanwhile mutants meet in a town hall
meeting there's one mutant climbing on
the ceiling Credit in this movie is
lizard man but this is actually
confirmed by Brett Ratner to be the
mutant and all the mutant fat Phat
shrinks and size to sit on a Pew Magneto
Rises to say no one ever talks about
extermination they just do it hinting at
his past at alitz we meet a mutant group
called The omegas in this film da
Ramirez plays Kalisto who has super
speed and the ability to detect a mutant
from afar this is actually a power from
the mutant caliban Ming melanon plays
psylock who will later be played by
Olivia mun and X-Men apocalypse omah
herota plays arklite a mutant who can
cast shock waves and Ken Leong who will
later play The Necromancer mil strm on
Lost plays kid omega as He's listed in
the script but based on his power set he
is absolutely the mutant quill and I
believe in other interviews they're like
yeah he's he's quill I don't know why we
called him kid Omega we see that kisto
has an Omega tattoo on her chest and
actually the term Omega comes from Omega
Level mutant in the comics that's the
most powerful class of mutants that
includes Jean Gray and W maximoff and
Franklin Richards actually later kalista
refers to some mutants that's class
three and later Charles says that Jee is
a class five and all this seems to be an
extension of this hierarchy structure
now remember between X2 and 2003 and
this movie in 2006 the success of the
first two X-Men and the first two
Spider-Man films led to things like
Daredevil and the Fantastic Four movies
and Marvel films and the odds just kind
of fell into a weird game of one
upmanship like how do we fit more
superheroes and more super villains and
more superpowers in these movies and it
really wasn't until 2008 with Iron Man
that Hollywood realized hey let's just
focus on one hero at a time and let's be
careful about how we build these
Ensemble team ups in specific ways to
combine power sets in unique
combinations that like make sense
visually with X-Men the Last Stand we
just kind of like throw a lot of
different powers against each other and
it's just kind of a mess but I still
like to watch X-Men the Last Stand
because it shows Kevin feige learning
these lessons the hard way yeah his name
is on these movies he was making a lot
of these decisions too Dr R introduced
secretary McCoy to Jimmy AKA leech who
is playing an Xbox game Xbox X-Men yeah
it is one of the first major Hollywood
movies to feature an Xbox it was a
relatively new gaming system in these
years actually Tik Tok Creator the
gaming Pastor was actually able to
figure out the exact game that Jimmy is
playing here and it is Pitfall the lost
expedition McCoy's hand reverts to flesh
colored around Jimmy X-Men first Class
establishes at Hank McCoy's appearance
as a result of him trying to cure his
own mutation in the past but instead he
accidentally introduced a secondary
mutation that caused him to become more
animalistic in appearance Scott sumers
follows Jean voice back to alkali Lake
where there is a brief shot of a
short-haired fam Jensen screaming
underwater this is traumatic so Scott
blasts the lake with his optic blast a
Whirlpool forms and the Phoenix Rises we
see a transformed Jee with longer hair
Charles later explains that Jee surviv
by being wrapped in a cocoon of
telekinetic activity but I guess that
cocoon did not stop her hair from
growing out Phoenix and Scott kiss and
we cut away before we see what happens
to scottt only his sunglasses are left
behind for Logan to find later he
doesn't even get an onscreen death
Charles tells Logan that Jean's Phoenix
identity manifested within her when he
put his psionic blocks in her mind and
control her again I just think this is a
missed opportunity making Jean's monster
coming from within her instead of where
it should be coming from the cosmos from
the unknown I look back at this as part
of a narrative trend of like trying to
ground these stories and what was seen
as a more understandable psychological
framework as opposed to just fullon
embracing Cosmic horror there was
actually a really great 2002 episod
episode of Jos Sweden's Buffy the
Vampire Slayer called normal again which
all the events of the series are
suggested to have been just a
psychological delusion within Buffy's
mind that episode's so great because you
know we just go back to the normal
reality of the show where Supernatural
events occur but we always wonder what
if phase one of the MCU would carry on
the tradition of trying to ground
everything in some kind of reality but
when The Buffy Creator Jos Sweden took
over the franchise of 2012's Avengers
notice what happened the MCU steered
into a cosmic Direction and definitely
found its voice and everything beyond
that was characters reacting to the fact
that wormholes to space exists that
Thanos say out there that Infinity
Stones exist comic book movies should
not be afraid of cosmic horror Ben
Foster plays an older Warren Worthington
the third in this movie he refuses to go
through the drug treatment he leaps out
the window this is a stunt that Ben
Foster reportedly did himself and he
flies over the city of San Francisco
toward KO Tower which fun fact is
designed to look like the nozzle of a
fire hose to honor our City's Brave
firefighters and how this city nearly
burnt to a crisp in the early 20th
century I live in San Francisco and
there is no like big high-rise with this
particular view of the city but they did
shoot this movie in Vancouver and they
likely composited in the background of
the city of San Francisco Magneto wrecks
the Convoy to free mystique and they
free the other imprisoners which
includes James madrock AKA Multiple Man
played by Eric danne from Grace anatomy
and later Euphoria next Juggernaut
played by Vinnie Jones actually came
into this role after working with
Matthew vau and locks stock in Two
Smoking Barrels and snatch in the comics
Juggernaut is not a mutant folks he is
Charles Xavier's stepbrother who winds
up finding the Crimson gem in the temple
of citak giving him superhuman strength
he wears his iconic Dome helmet to
protect him from mental attacks and
while he's not a mutant he off aligns
with and fights for the Brotherhood of
mutants but none of that backstory is
true in this film he's just a mutant
Matthew Von actually told superhero hype
in 2005 that he was hoping to put his
friend vny Jones in the movie because
quote what's interesting about
Juggernaut is that he's the brother
Professor X that's why I thought it
would be interesting to have an English
Thug opposite Patrick Stewart instead
Brett rner just uses the character as a
battering ram Mystique steps in front of
a dart to save Magneto and immediately
loses her powers Magneto abandons her
and the character just kind of
disappears from the movie we just see
her one time later where it reveals that
like she shared information with the
government it's clear that with James
Mars and Rebeca raain a lot of these
actors were just kind of like done with
the franchise Logan and Jean find
themselves in Reverse positions from
where they met in the first film there
are three nodes on her chest wires
across her neck I don't know maybe you
could see this as foreshadowing for the
way Logan will have to kill her with
three claws to the Torso later they make
out and Logan's pretty freaked out he
asks what happened to Scott and the lab
goes crazy and Jean says K me yeah it's
impossible for a character to say kill
me and for it not to be a reference to
alien or
aliens kill me
[Music]
please kill me Logan tells her that
Charles can fix it and the Phoenix
returns I don't want to fix
it Jean escapes Logan storman Charles
deduce that she must have killed Scott
and no one feels anything they just kind
of move on and they return to Jean's
neighborhood and there is this
ridiculous shot wait for me here what I
need to see Jean
alone you were right
Charles this one is special did they not
see Magneto standing there in the middle
of the street with Juggernaut as they
approach the house notice how Magneto is
back in his helmet we should note that
Magneto's helmet in the comics was not
historically known to block out psionic
waves that was just kind of an invention
for the first X-Men film and they
adopted it and other media thereafter
and in fact at times in the comics the
helmet was known to give Magneto
telepathy Charles and Eric confront Jean
who unleashes her telekinesis on the
house to try to repel Charles Logan and
storm charge in Juggernaut despite being
told to keep them out just kind of
throws Wolverine directly into the
living room storm fights Kalisto who
throws her from the left and then Zips
around to catch her on the right very
cool a deleted scene would have shown
storm conducting lightning through
Wolverine to electrocute Juggernaut
until he passed out you can tell the VFX
artist worked really hard to manifest
Phoenix's Powers with some trippy
Illusions like having the water pour
from the sink and flatten on the ceiling
it's just because all we know of the
Phoenix in this movie is that she's some
evil alternate identity inside of Jean's
mind we don't really know why this
telekinesis matters it's just kind of
like random sorcery the psychic battle
between Charles and Phoenix lifts
Charles out of the chair everything
slows down as Logan Witnesses Charles's
final moments don't let it control
you
char Charles is completely obliterated
and it's the first of three times we
will see Charles Xavier
[Music]
die storm eulogizes Charles who gets a
massive headstone and an eternal flame
we should note at this point there is
still not a headstone or a service for
Scott Summers and I honestly think
rewatch in this movie it's because when
they shot these seeds they didn't yet
know how much of the movie Scott Summers
was going to be in like they needed all
those actors to be there for the funeral
scene and I just think that it's
possible that they didn't know at that
point when they were making this movie
that they were going to kill off Cyclops
at that point Magneto brings Jee back to
his Brotherhood campsite a lot of REI
Vibes at this point in the movie folks
Jean dismantles a serum gun and aims the
darts at Eric calling back when Magneto
redirected The Guns of the cops outside
the train station in the first movie a
deleted scene would have shown Jean
demonstrating her power by turning a cup
into a glowing ball of energy sending
shock waves through the camp that's why
in the scene after this with the omegas
and Pyro complaining about Jean Gray you
can see other Brotherhood mutants in the
back just trying to put their REI gear
back up now it's not really clear where
this campsite is I assume Marin County
since they all have to go to the bridge
on foot but there are definitely
mountains that I'm pretty sure are just
like Canada outside of Vancouver scenes
in this part of the movie are crazy
folks we jump around from these Woods
we're in Westchester New York then we're
in the St Francisco Bay area there's a
clinic that Bobby and Pyro are outside
of where it says Washington is it
Washington State or Washington D and
then Logan from Westchester responds to
psychic Visions from Jee and just kind
of like knows where in all of North
America to go find her in the middle of
this we see a section where military
soldiers are transferring their weapons
from metal ones to plastic ones with
serum darts and there's actually a vocal
Cameo by R Lee Army from Full Metal
Jacket who's barking at all of them
Wolverine fights with bone dagger
slinging mutant Spike who's played by
Lance Gibson this is based on the
character Spike introduced in exforce in
2001 and along with fat were members of
the ecstatics comic team this fight
scene that was actually added to make it
a more even fight because otherwise the
sequence would have just been Wolverine
arriving in the woods at the Brotherhood
camp and suddenly massacring mutant he
came across so notice instead they
intercut Wolverine killing these other
mutants who don't even seem to be
attacking him with these new shots of
the bone daggers flying at him like
killing all these other random people
was in self-defense because he was that
bad at Spike Charles finds Wolverine and
flings him across the woods meanwhile
the president and tras send a task force
to the Brotherhood camp but they use
multiple man as a decoy back at the
Mansion the X-Men suit up and their
suits are all black leather Hank McCoy
after designing has now gone back to
like his pants and a shirtless vest nice
while Wolverine storm Ice band Shadow
Cat and Colossus all have alternate
color trim on their respective suits
storm suit as a silver Cape now I got to
say The Last Stand is in my opinion in
the lower tier of Xmen movies at least
when it comes to the suit up and charg
in the final battle like really we don't
even get Rogue even Bobby Drake is like
do we really want this to be the final
fight of the movie I'm happy to sit out
but hey there was a deleted scene that
would have shown Beast reciting
Shakespeare's Henry VI F Act 4 wait be
happy few we Band of Brothers for He Who
sheds his blood with me this day shall
be my brother be he near so vile this
day shall gentle his condition and men
in England now are bed will count their
manhoods cheap they were not here with
us to fight on Chris's day so here's the
big moment Magneto attacks the Golden
Gate Bridge and again he really just
does this so that Juggernaut doesn't
have to swim or take a fery to Alcatraz
in the car we see these kids playing hey
again it's Pitfall the last Expedition
yes leech's favorite game makes the
second cameo in this movie except notice
they are playing on a PlayStation and I
don't know why they both have
controllers this a single player game
and they have a PlayStation in their car
in 2006 wow now this attack on the
Golden Gate Bridge as I mentioned before
was a massive set piece it involved
millions of dollars with the scale model
that they used for the effects planning
and then a larger 112th scale model that
they can move around to make the Flying
Bridge effects but having this in the
movie was deemed super important because
after 9 11 Hollywood was still afraid to
stage implosions and explosions in New
York City or in Washington DC executive
producer Lauren Scher Donner's husband
Richard Donner stage a scene in the 1978
Superman film that was on the Golden
Gate Bridge there's actually a moment
during the run of the new X-Men comics
in 2003 where Magneto takes over New
York City by ripping up all the bridges
and metal substructure he was high on
the mutant drug kick at the time Kevin
feige as brsh to this movie even said
that they used that moment from the
comics as inspiration for how to show
Magneto's incredible power though he
incorrectly cited the ultimate Xmen
Magneto moves the bridge so that it
connects out has two what looks like the
Fort Mason part of San Francisco while
the bridge would not be able to stay
suspended like that over the water
without its support beams going down
into the mud under the bay I will admit
that the actual length of the bridge
would probably cover the distance
between Alcatraz and the shoreline
Magneto stops the Juggernaut from
charging in initially by saying in chess
the pawns go first yes because the way
Charles and Eric frame this whole
conflict is a chess match but
unfortunately on the other side of the
table Charles isn't there for Eric to
play against so you know his heart
really isn't in this battle we see one
of these mutants teleporting forward
this could be vanisher who will make an
appearance on the xforce in Deadpool 2
played by a much more recognizable actor
now the human soldiers are firing these
serum darts and they have so many of
them they include these cluster grenades
that just spray out like hundreds of
them one of the early casualties on the
Brotherhood side is glob Herman a mutant
whose powers are literally just
transparent wax skin we see anol the
lizard man changing and falling from his
perch arklite finally steps in by
sending in shock waves the Blackbird
arrives and Beast says this oh my St and
G yes this is one of BEAST's most
verbose catchphrases Beast first says
this in 1975's Avengers number 137
supposedly it was Kevin figy who really
pushed for him to get this line in the
film Magneto sends it a second wave the
mutant Ash burdens Some Humans the X-Men
arrive and face off against the
Brotherhood and Magneto says traitors to
their own course and so far this charge
is the closest thing we've gotten to
X-Men vers Brotherhood charge in the
'90s animated show intro among these
attacks a deleted scene would have shown
storm summoning a wave from the bay and
then electrocuting in the water other
deleted shots have shown ican freezing
and smashing fat and Beast breaking a
mutant's neck backwards what we do see
though is Kitty bride running through a
person and grabbing him from behind to
slam him down and the comic she has
ripped out a heart before so I'm glad
she didn't do that here or you know it
would have been pretty cool if she did
Juggernaut charges in the lab to kill
Jimmy yeah we definitely heard the sound
of bowling pins there Kitty races after
him Wolverine slashes this mutant who
can regenerate his limbs this guy's name
is apparently starfish I don't think
there's a mutant named starfish in
Marvel Comics but I guess they just
created another regenerative mutant just
for this bit come
on grow those back I actually would love
for Logan to call this back while
fighting Deadpool in Deadpool 3 Kitty
pulls Juggernaut through the floor and
traps him there
briefly don't you know who I
am I'm the Juggernaut
[__] H you got him I love it quill AKA
kid Omega kills Dr R with the world's
worst hug otherwise I got to say pretty
useless power set and he's considered
one of the omegas I don't know I would
take fat Juggernaut chases Kitty through
the facility she reaches Jimmy but leech
dampens her powers so that she has to
trick Juggernaut into knock himself out
a removed version of the scene would
have had him referencing The Shining by
saying here's Juggy yes jugy storm kills
Kalisto electrifying her against a metal
fence this crazy detail so you can see
her lip rings sizzling and cool down
Magneto and Pyro escalate the battle by
launching cars that pyro blows up it's
essentially the same setup from the
danger room defensive practice session
for the beginning of the movie Wolverine
remembers they have to work as a team
and he has Colossus throw him fastball
special style at Magneto but it was just
a distraction for Beast to sneak up from
behind and inject Magneto with the Cure
and a deleted SE Magneto would have
actually tortured Wolverine by bending
the adamantium all over his body causing
excruciating pain so seeing Eric lyncher
losing his power Phoenix finally steps
in and she starts obliterating everyone
and everything only Wolverine with his
regenerative powers can withstand this
and Jean starts with his suit and we're
kind of back to that flirty line from
the first movie couldn't wait to get my
shirt up again could you Jean is able to
break through all this madness and she
begs Wolverine to save her and he snicks
through her stomach back at the Mansion
two smaller headstones are finally put
up for Scott Summers and Jean Gray Rogue
reveals that she took the Cure and she
and Bobby hold hands but there is an
alternate ending where Rogue says that
she couldn't go through with it either
way assuming this cure is ultimately
ineffective based off of the scene with
Magneto if Rogue and Bobby ever escalate
Beyond handholding yeah look out Bobby
you're going to look like colossus's
doodle we learned that Beast is now the
ambassador to the UN which makes me
wonder who's going to take his place as
Secretary of mutant Affairs I think
auror Monroe would be a good candidate
Angel flies past the Golden Gate Bridge
which is now under repair and we see
Eric lyncher sitting at a chest table by
himself two other players play with red
and white pieces kind of reminding us of
the red and white sides of mutants
versus humans in X2 Eric lyncher ever so
slightly is able to nedge his metal
piece his powers are returning that
piece is the king we are reminded of th
Twi The Once and Future King but you
only ever move your King as a defensive
move to avoid a Checkmate or to topple
it to Signal defeat and ultimately
despite his powers coming back here I
think Eric lyncher is admitting defeat
because he has lost his friend who he
would be playing this chess game with or
did he because post credit scene takes
us back to MOA MCT tager hospital room
morning hello
Moira Charles oh boy so presumably
Charles is not dead his consciousness
just transferred to this patient but the
X-Men film series never really picks up
with this there is an alternate ending
or a post-edit scene that would have
taken Logan back to that Alberta Canada
bar with the same bartender from the
first X-Men film you headed
home something like that okay Deadpool 3
spoilers coming in the danger room I
avoided talking about Storm's new
haircut in this movie halberry got an
awesome glow up for this role and it's
so memorable that fans who follow
halberry on social media were pretty
curious ious over a May 2023 Instagram
post that showed Hal Berry with a new
white spiky de could this mean that we
are going to see Hy Berry storm in
Deadpool 3 thank you so much for
watching this next week we're going to
be talking about X-Men Origins Wolverine
a movie that's probably going to get
quite a few callbacks in Deadpool 3 I
want to thank Eric Wu and Brandon bar
for helping me write this script you can
support new rock stars by grabbing some
merch From Nerd ride. shop follow me on
all social platforms at eaos And
subscribe to all three channels in the
new rockstars Network thanks for
watching and I'll see you next time
bye